[Music]
welcome back to this special edition of
hannity
today president trump traveled to new
york city to visit his brother robert
who is hospitalized with a very serious
illness
fox news's alex hogan is live with the
very latest on this alex
trey right now the president is in new
jersey but earlier today he stopped here
at wheel cornell medicine
here on the upper east side of manhattan
where his brother robert
is hospitalized the president making
that stop for
about an hour the white house not
elaborating on his condition
but saying that he is seriously ill
robert is the
youngest of five siblings and at his
press briefing today the president
commenting on their close brotherly bond
i have a wonderful brother we've had a
great relationship
for a long time for from day one it's a
long time ago
and he's in the hospital right now and
hopefully he'll be all right but he's
he's pretty he's having a hard time
the 72 year old served as a former top
executive within the trump organization
he married his longtime partner in march
and two months ago robert trump filed a
temporary
restraining order to try to block a
tell-all book by his niece mary
the state supreme court judge rejecting
that request
earlier this year robert was
hospitalized for about a week but
there's still
no word on his condition trey
alex hogan thank you